bonsoir Monsieur Clichy alors on a eu
dimanche l'Irak l'Algérie l'Arabie
Saoudite les Émirats arabes unis qui ont
annoncé une réduction de leur production
de pétrole 10 ans on veut stabiliser le
marché c'était quoi le problème avec
l'état du marché monsieur Clichy
il m'a un prix un prix plancher que
c'est 80 dollars en 80-90 dollars le
Barry c'est ça qui veut le dire donc il
faut se rappeler que ces pays-là sont
des pays qui dépendent énormément du
pétrole pour leur pour leur budget
nationaux pour leur recette fiscale et
il contrôle 50% du marché mondial donc
ils ont beaucoup aimé l'année 2022
l'année 2022 a été
une année exceptionnelle il y a des
profits records pour les compagnies
nationales d'électricité dans ces
pays-là la moyenne ça a été environ 80
dollars 100 dollars le Barry mais on
partait de 120$ lors du début de la
guerre en Ukraine à 80 dollars à la fin
de l'année et donc ça ça fait une
moyenne de et ces derniers temps en mars
dernier les prêts ont baissé à 70
dollars ça c'est moins intéressant donc
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire on va diminuer
la
disponibilité de pétrole sur leur marché
pour créer une pression à la hausse et
remonter dans la zone confortable de
80-90 dollars le Berry le peuple était
entendre que on parle de ralentissement
économique des craintes de récession
accentuées peut-être d'ailleurs avec les
turbulences bancaires aux États-Unis et
on disait craindre une accumulation de
stocks un peu partout dans le monde
jusqu'à quel point ça leur ça pourrait
leur nuire ça et jusqu'à quel point la
décision qui a été prise peut profiter à
la Russie au passage
comment il faut comprendre cette
décision de le populiste une mesure qui
est préventive on veut garder le marché
très serré pour mettre encore une fois
maintenir les prix dans cette dans cette
échelle de 80 à 90 dollars et on le fait
aussi parce qu'on anticipe des problèmes
économiques on se dit on crée beaucoup
une situation comme 2008 ou 2020 où les
prix ont plongé de façon très très
subite ces pays-là encore une fois
dépend de ses revenus là veut l’éviter
absolument cette situation-là donc on se
disent dès qu'on voit des signaux un peu
au rouge on va baisser un peu la
disponibilité de pétrole pour garder les
prix élevés et évidemment un prix élevé
avec des ventes moindres ça fait quand
même des profits intéressants pour la
Russie bien sûr les deux grands
décideurs dans cette décision là c'est
l'Arabie Saoudite parce que les plus
grandes réserves le plus grandes
production mondiale au plus bas prix ça
c'est c'est connu mais la Russie
également donc Arabie réussi deuxième
producteur troisième producteur la
Russie est en guerre a besoin de
prélever pour elle en 2022 en vendant
moins mais avec des prix plus élevés
elle a fait quand même aussi des revenus
très intéressants donc pourquoi pour
faire perdurer la situation en 2023 pour
ces pays-là c'est très c'est gagnant
gagnant mais pour les pays consommateurs
et pour les consommateurs eux-mêmes ça
vient avec toutes sortes de crainte on a
des analystes dans certaines banques
américaines qui évoquaient dans la
foulée de cette décision de l'OPE un
prix du baril de pétrole de retour
autour des 100 d'ici la fin de l'année
est-ce que c'est un scénario plausible
et quel serait l'effet tout ça on
commençait à avoir un apaisement de
l'inflation monsieur clache est-ce que
ça pourrait renverser la tendance c'est
clair que c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
parce que tout augmentation des prix du
pétrole on le sait le pétrole ça sert à
faire déplacer les marchandises au
déplacement etc donc c'est clair que ça
fait une pression inflationniste très
importante que qui repose un défi pour
les autorités monétaires donc ça c'est
sûr mais il faut quand même se rappeler
qu'en 2022 en octobre 2022 les pays de
l'opus ont baissé leur production de 2
millions de barils de pétrole par jour
tout le monde s'attendait à une hausse
marquer des prix de l'essence horizon
diminué parce que il y avait des
craintes de récession la Chine était
toujours en confinement il y avait pas
de reprise de la consommation chinoise
du côté énergétique donc les prix
finalement ont baissé donc on peut pas
faire directement une corrélation entre
le geste d'aujourd'hui et une hausse
automatique des prêts à l'essence il
faut que ça perdure dans le temps un bon
trois semaines pour voir effectivement
des conséquences sur le prix par contre
pour la période estivale il y a souvent
une hausse de la consommation hausse de
la demande de la part des automobilistes
et pour le transport également est-ce
que cette pression sur les prix pourrait
se maintenir jusqu'à l'été par exemple
oui c'est sûr que ça arrive pas dans le
bon contexte mais c'était certainement
le calcul de l'OPE plus ce sont dit bon
ben là maintenant c'est l'été qui arrive
on va avoir une augmentation de la
consommation les gens vont quand même
vouloir voyager puis ils vont consommer
des barils de pétrole donc de l'essence
et puis ça va être profitable pour nous
donc c'est clair que là faut voir faut
voir quelle sera la réaction faut voir
si il va avoir une répercussion sur les
prix de l'essence et si cette hausse
envisagée ou attendu va faire en sorte
qu'il y a les gens vont changer leur
plan de déplacement ça c'est à voir pour
l'été qui s'en vient avec nous
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]